normalement oui je coupe des fruits
frais de fruits ou des sandwichs et
légumes coupés et là on a tout arrêté ça
pour que je les aide à faire les
commandes téléphoniques
le oui bonjour madame dame ou s'il vous
plaît mouvaux parfait c'est mieux pour
vous c'est mieux pour vous on commence
la plupart des gens qu'on appelle pour
faire les commandes téléphoniques la
plupart ce sont des personnes âgées le
café est loin de quarantaine il georges
un peu avec nous parce qu'elles sont
confinés dans leurs appartements peuvent
pas sortir ça lui fait une personne à
josé gens l'ont la peau vraiment en rosé
mais on les écoute parce que dans mon
corps moi je les écoute 12h12 un centre
en spéciale
c'est difficile pour moi de voir que ces
gens là sont isolés parce que souvent
ces gens lyon personnes dont les livres
les familles peuvent pas aller les voir
son sont chez eux
ce triste maladie
pour moi ça fait du bien quand je sens
que j'ai fait mon dieu je lui rends
service pic capuche et le sang qui sont
contentes
c'est sûr que c'est un service essentiel
aux deux enfants et font manger faut
toujours on fait toujours falloir manger
c'est un défi pour nous de passer dans
les allées parce que les avis sont pas
large quand on voit qu'un criant sans
vie monsters ont l'espace et où on
attend au bout de l'ailé on laisse
passer les gens sont de plus en plus
nerveux chez inquiète à plus qui se
parle c'est sûr mais faut pas que j'y
pense je pense que je m'en viens
travailler comme c'était
maud janvier je m'en viens servez les
clients sont contents quand je finis ma
journée je compte en jeu fatigué mais
content
[Musique]
et